(dramatic music)
- Welcome to A Conversation With History.
I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our distinguished guest
today is Jim Peebles
who is one of the world's
foremost cosmologists
and Emeritus Professor
at Princeton University,
where, since 1984,
he was the Albert Einstein
Professor of Science.
Professor Peebles is
the Hitchcock professor
on the Berkeley campus for
the fall 2006 semester.
Jim, welcome to Berkeley.
- Thank you.
- Where were you born and raised?
- In Manitoba, the center of Canada,
to the south of the province in the born,
and early life in St. Boniface,
the sister city of Winnipeg,
then later in St. Vital,
public schools, small schools,
and then on to the University of Manitoba.
- And looking back, how
do you think your parents
shaped you're thinking about the world,
or maybe in your case, I
should say the Universe.
- We didn't talk about the Universe.
My father though was
very good with his hands.
He built things,
and that very much grabbed my attention.
I, as a youth, didn't pay too
much attention to the stars,
although I remember being
impressed by Aurora,
but I did pay a lot of
attention to building things.
I'd build sleds
I'd build inexpensive radio receivers.
I liked to work with my hands,
and that I think must have
been inspired by my father.
- As a young person, did you,
were you drawn to science.
I mean, in talking in high
school, middle school.
- I didn't know what
science was in high school.
It wasn't a, I shouldn't complain.
It was a good school.
I learned things,
but I didn't learn very
much about modern science,
even modern mathematics.
It was quite a shock to go to university.
- Mm-hmm, and you've
mentioned your university.
In what way were you shocked,
and what did you major in after the shock?
- It was a wonderful place.
So many bright people doing
so many interesting things.
Because I was not a diligent
student in high school,
I didn't have a clear
idea what I wanted to do
except that I did feel I'd like
to continue with education.
I knew I liked to build things,
so I went to, I enrolled at
the university in engineering.
That was okay, and I guess I could have
become a mediocre engineer,
but to my great good fortune,
friends persuaded me to
transfer over to physics.
I can't say it was a eureka moment,
I just stopped complaining
(Harry laughing)
and started doing my homework.
- so it felt natural to you?
- [James] Somehow it felt right.
- [Harry] Yeah
- And I never looked back.
I've never had asked myself should I
have done something else.
No, this was right for me.
- Did you have any
teachers at the university
that were very influential
in pointing you in a--
- Super, super.
It's not a world famous
university perhaps,
but there were excellent faculty,
and they really inspired me in physics.
I consider myself a
physicist, not an astronomer,
and I learned, I took
no courses in astronomy.
I didn't even know about
stars when I left Manitoba.
- And then where did you
go to graduate school?
- Princeton University in New Jersey.
I came there intending
to continue my interest
in quantum physics, particle physics,
but didn't although there
were excellent people
doing that sort of thing at Princeton.
Instead I met my lifelong
teacher from then on, Bob Dicke,
who inspired me to follow him.
He had been a great
contributor to quantum optics.
In the years from the second
world war into the 50s,
he was one of the leading figures
in figuring out quantum optics,
the development of measures and lasers.
Some wonderfully ingenious
inventions in that field,
but then he decided gravity physics
was being very neglected as a subject
for research in physics.
He started working on that,
and what he was doing was so fascinating,
I just trailed along.
- And what what did you wind
up doing your dissertation on,
I assume, under his influence?
- Under his influence, project of,
you know there is in
physics constants of nature,
the numbers that
characterize interactions,
in particular the strength
of the electromagnetic interaction
is measured by a number
called the fine-structure constant.
Bob was fascinated by the question
could such numbers be not
fixed numbers but rather vary.
It was on his part more philosophical
than based on anything firm.
Somewhat ironic that these
days within superstring theory,
people are convinced these
numbers ought to vary
with time and maybe
slightly with position.
In any case, he set me
the task find evidence,
though we constrained how much this number
could have varied through time.
Turns out there are lots of ways to do it.
In particular in those days,
one had pretty well
developed already the concept
of radioactive decay,
of long-lived isotopes,
as a method of measuring
the ages of rocks.
Different radio activities
decay at different rates,
leave different products.
You can count the products, deduce an age,
under the assumption that
the decay rate is constant,
but if the strength of the
electromagnetic interaction
were varying, that would
change the decay rate,
and so different decay chains would
give inconsistent answers.
Kind of neat, so I learned some geology,
which I'd never done before,
and I learned some astronomy
because you can also
look at great distances.
You see things as they were in the past,
and again make some checks.
So my thesis, in a way,
was leading up to some very modern ideas.
I had no idea of course.
- [Harry] Mm-hmm, and I get
the sense in your lecture,
and what you're saying now,
that this community that you're a part of,
and it may actually transcend
the particular subfield
within physics, it may
include all of the sciences,
that there's a kind of movement forward,
as the collaborations emerge,
or the insights emerged,
which then influence your own thinking.
You just suggested that
in your dissertation.
- Oh, yes, yes, we build
upon previous work.
It's so important that we
have a basis of knowledge
and understanding that we build upon,
and we hope add to, for
the next generation.
By no means is any one individual,
one of my heroes is Bob Dicke, my teacher,
but I have to admit he
wasn't essential to the game.
Other's would have done what he did.
What is essential is that
institutional memory.
I sometimes think of science as a craft.
- [Harry] Mm-hmm.
- In the sense that you learn it
from the previous
generation who learned it
from their previous generation.
I would hate to imagine
doing science de neuvo.
- [Harry] Mm-hmm.
- You would, to start all over again
would be to start all over again.
We'd have to go through another
Galileo, another Newton.
- [Harry] Mm-hmm.
This touches on a question
that I always like to ask the scientists.
That is, what are the skills
that people should have,
and also what are the virtues
that make for a good scientist?
- In part, what's the most optimum skill,
is a function of time.
As the subject evolves,
different skills are needed.
I have the strong feeling, for example,
that another respected
figure, Fritz Zwicky,
was just right for his time in astronomy
when there were lots of
new ideas poorly explored,
but might not have done so well today
when we have a fixed set
of ideas that we're trying
to build upon.
He was too independent minded in a way.
It's good to be independent of course,
but you have also to pay attention
to what other people are thinking.
He didn't like doing that.
That was right for his time, now it's not.
But of course there are
surely general features
that people should should carry along,
and one of them, intellectual honesty.
Did I really say that,
you may ask yourself,
oh, what a stupid thing to do.
In life it's very difficult
to say that sometimes,
but if you're going to do well in science,
you'd better learn from your mistakes.
So that is one, I think, introspection.
Ask yourself, did I really mean that,
and is this observation really consistent
with my fixed beliefs?
Of course, there are many
kinds of science too.
There is the deeply mathematical sort,
like superstring theory.
Those guys can't pay too
much attention to the data,
'cause there isn't much that's relevant
to their deep ideas.
On the other hand, the kind
of science I love doing
is that which is comes
into pretty close contact
with what people are measuring,
and there I see a lovely interplay.
What are the observations suggesting?
What is the theory suggest?
Are they really consistent?
Curiosity of course, in
any human endeavor surely.
An interest in what's going on.
Mathematics, I have never been
a very good mathematician.
I struggle with it.
I hate it.
- [Harry] Must be speaking
relatively speaking.
- I don't know but I,
it is true I think that
I only do mathematics
because it produces this
wonderful interaction
between theory and observation.
I think if that weren't happening
I would do something less difficult.
What would it be, I don't know.
(both laughing)
- (stumbling over words) Well, go ahead.
Did you want anything else?
Because I was just gonna--
- No, no, let's go on.
- Well, one of the themes
that emerged in your lectures,
and often in my discussion
with scientists,
is a willingness to collaborate,
but also compete, basically.
- Oh yes, oh yes.
We're a nasty bunch.
We try to get ahead on the other person.
That's partly, I guess, just
human instinct, isn't it?
You like to run faster than that friend
next to you when you jog.
Competition, it's not unhealthy,
but cooperation, we don't
get nowhere without it,
and so, yes, I have to admit,
you have the better argument there,
but I'm gonna get you next time.
Competition very important though, why?
As I reached the golden years,
I feel less competitive,
but I still want to beat
out that other person.
(both laughing)
- That's good.
Let me see if there was something else.
Yeah, I did want to emphasize
again something you just said,
but you said it in the lecture.
There's really this synergy
between theory and observations.
That is, you know, it's
really an important part
of this work that you're doing.
- It is so important.
Of course, this is what science
is, in my way of thinking.
The synergy, it's been
there since the beginning.
When we run out of synergy,
then science goes in a
very different direction,
and one that I'm not
sure I want to to follow.
There was never any guarantee, you know,
that this synergy would be useful.
No one ever guaranteed that
we'd be able to make sense
of the world around us.
It's a striking thing that
we've gone as far as we have,
and we've come in an amazingly long way.
All of modern technology so much depends
on that curiosity-driven research,
the synergy of a decade
ago, a century ago.
Will it continue?
We'll find out.
- You were talking yesterday
in your introduction,
the second lecture,
and you're talking about what science is,
and you said "Science is a search
"for successive approximations.
"Good approximation to reality,
"but a long way to go.
"No absolute truth in
the physical sciences."
So in a way you
have to live with
uncertainty and frustration,
I guess, if you're going
to live by that ethos.
- Oh yes, you know there is talk
of the theory of everything.
I think it's poorly chosen words.
They don't really mean that.
No one in physical
science fools themselves
into thinking we know absolute truth.
Always, always, we have to accept
that although we have brilliant successes,
we also have amazing gaps
in our understanding.
The gaps are being filled,
and it is characteristic
of our subjects so far
that as you fill gaps, you open new ones,
new questions arise.
I wanted to emphasize that
because one misconception
about science often is
that look if you can't
answer all my questions
then you don't know what
you're talking about,
but that isn't true in science.
We can answer some questions very well,
and we can prove it by the technology
to which these answers bring us,
but at the same time
there are open issues.
And of course, if there
weren't those open issues,
there'd would be no more science to do,
and we're not in any danger
of being in that state.
- Now this relates, I think, to a problem
that science probably has
in its broader environment
that is the field,
which is that really key here is is doing,
basic science is very important
because there the people
who fund the science,
whether it's the government
or the foundations, whatever,
can say well what's this for,
you know, why should we do.
So that is a really key element.
So this uncertainty as one looks
for these approximations
to move toward truth
is also enveloped in big questions
whose relevance might
not be clear to people
who are not doing the work.
- And we must emphasize the
excitement, the adventure,
of exploring new questions,
and on occasion, finding answers.
That excitement I believe
carries on to excitement
in more applied areas of physical science.
I've got a hope that an engineer
who develops the next
generation of cell phones,
they should only make them
not work in automobiles,
will be in part excited
by what the engineer
sees around herself of
advances in other fields,
including the most basic.
I would never claim, maybe
I'll will be wrong someday,
I'd never claimed that
my subject is going to be
of any practical use.
Who cares what's going on
on that distant galaxy,
except that you really do care.
Isn't it neat to think
you can deduce properties
of a galaxy way over on the other side
of the observable Universe.
Neat to think that we can
understand its nature, in broad outline,
even though we'll never
be able to go over there
and poke our finger on
a planet in that galaxy
and ask who's home.
Intellectual excitement, I
hope, is an essential part
of our society and of its growth.
- You're touching on something,
because, you know, people
who don't do physics
are really interested in the stars.
They're stargazers.
I mean of course there's all,
one level we know the
interest in science fiction,
you know and what's you
know beyond what we can see
with the naked eye, and so on,
and then of course it gets into
a moral dimension, you know.
Who are we, you know, what is man,
how were we placed here, and so on.
So any thoughts about how
physics can lead to a place
where other people are posing questions,
although they have no interest
in the physical science.
- A remark about physics and astronomy,
many people are fascinated by astronomy.
It's astronomy's secret weapon.
Surely congressional aides
are a little bit biased toward astronomy.
I am now, what am I called,
I am now a naturalized citizen.
I was for many years a landed immigrant.
I actually had a green card
that was green, that old,
and in those days, when
arriving from a trip overseas,
I would have to explain
to customs and immigration
what I did for a living,
and I would sometimes
say I'm an astronomer.
"Oh, isn't that interesting"
(Harry laughing)
or I might say I'm a physicist.
"I took physics in
school, and I hated it."
You notice that there are
amateur astronomy clubs.
These people are marvelous.
They work all day at a job,
and then at night, they do
what they love, astronomy.
I'm so embarrassed.
I do what I love during the day.
There are no, I know of
no amateur physics club,
amateur particle physics.
Wouldn't it be marvelous
if there was such a club?
But there aren't.
So that's the way people are.
To me, I don't really draw a distinction
between astronomy and particle physics,
and I don't see any moral
aspect to it all either,
to be blunt.
It's all part of the world around us.
The small, the big, they're both neat,
but I wouldn't give precedent
to one over the other, I think.
- I wonder if you would compare
the awe that that you feel
as a scientist,
as you come to understand
these these structures
of the Universe,
to say the awe that somebody feels
who just, you know, emotionally
appreciates what they say
by just looking at the stars, so to speak.
- Or looking at a giant redwood.
- [Harry] Yeah.
- Is the awe any different
- [Harry] Yeah, that's the question.
- To me, no.
There is the awe of realizing
that we can make sense
of the world around us.
Sometimes when I look at
our political situation
I don't have that awe,
but when I look at what
can be done in astronomy,
I am awed but when I
look at what can be done
with the subatomic nature
of matter, I'm awed too.
It's both neat,
and so is a tree or a person.
I've just been reading a wonderful history
of the discovery of DNA.
What an awesome set of work, brilliant,
and I'm awed by the structure of DNA.
- Do you think, you know, if you think
about the future of science,
we have to train the next generation,
even, you know, at the lower
grades so there is a commitment
to this doing of science,
to discover truth,
that you know even in
the very young grades,
we have to develop the skills there
so people can go to high
school, and then go to college,
and then, if they choose, go get a PhD
but on the other hand, you
know, the political currents
are really calling that
into question, you know,
around issues, not directly
related to what you do,
I'm just curious, as a
scientist, what your thoughts
are about that.
How do we be build a legitimacy of science
in those communities where
it's become problematic.
- I wish I could answer that.
I'm sure that a lot of the
development of a scientist
takes place in public
schools in the lower grades.
I have no idea how that's best done.
Of course so much of it depends
on the home environment.
I was so lucky, although I
didn't learn much in the way
of formal science until university,
I was so lucky in having parents
that allowed me to build things.
I could make a mess in the backyard,
and they didn't care.
I have taught all my life,
but I must say I hold
in awe those teachers
in public schools for the much
deeper challenge they have.
After all, when I teach,
I'm talking to the choir.
If the class is a little unruly,
I lower my voice and they all settle down.
(Harry laughing)
It's just so different,
but of course once we've got
these people in university,
then indeed there are
things that can be done
and must be done to keep them on the track
to doing great things,
and one of the most important certainly
is a little bit of support
for interesting new research
that will inspire them,
perhaps to continue doing
research after education,
or perhaps to go into something different
but apply their skills.
Not very expensive as a
fraction of the budget
of this country to keep research going.
It's being squeezed these days.
For small groups, the
National Science Foundation
is a major source of support.
It is being terribly squeezed
so that many scientists
who are doing small science,
but that's so, but that's the backbone,
the small science groups that
are teaching small groups
of students to go out and
do wonderful new things,
are being squeezed to the point that many
are closing down.
The National Science Foundation
is running out of money
for small groups that are at
the very basis for education.
- I would like to change directions now,
and have you help me make
our audience understand,
maybe they already do but
let's start from beginning.
You are a cosmologist.
What is it that this field of
the physical sciences studies?
- The easy answer is the Universe,
but of course it's also the wrong answer.
The Universe is everything.
I don't study you
(Harry chuckles)
So when I say I'm studying--
(both laughing)
Yeah, I'm shocked! (laughing)
I'll try to work you in,
but when I say I'm studying the Universe,
I really mean I'm
studying what the Universe
looks like on the
largest observable scale.
It's a little surprising that
I could make such a statement.
How do I know there's a
largest observable scale?
To be a little more
explicit then I should say
we observe that matter is arranged
in a sort of hierarchy of structures.
You and I are a little
concentration of material
here in the sprawl of the
Bay area on the planet Earth,
that's in the solar system,
that's in a galaxy of stars,
it's in a super cluster
of stars, and so on.
Layer upon layer of structure.
It's kind of a neat arrangement,
and of course it goes down in size too.
But what is striking is that as you look
on successively larger scales,
you reach a point where
there is no more structure.
The distribution of material
objects becomes uniform.
No center that we can see, no edge.
It's that wonderfully simple arrangement
that is the basis for what we study
when we're studying the
large-scale structure
of the Universe.
What is the nature of that
large-scale distribution,
and what it is its behavior?
It's been speculated for a long time,
fairly recently demonstrated,
that this uniform distribution
is nearly uniformly expanding.
It contains fossils
from the early Universe,
in particular, thermal radiation.
The radiation is cooling.
It is observed that distant
galaxies look younger,
and that makes sense,
because we're seeing them
as they were in the past
because of the limited light travel time,
We're seeing evolution.
We're seeing the growth of departures
from this large scale uniformity,
matter is growing together in clumps,
and the clumps are growing
together in clumps of clumps.
We are studying the
growth of the big levels
in this hierarchy of structure.
- And is the concern, only peripherally,
how it all started?
- Oh, of course you'd love
to answer that question.
You make it peripheral if you
can't give it a good answer,
and it's debated whether
we have a good answer.
To me, as an old-fashioned
theory and observation type guy,
we don't have yet a definitive answer.
We have some very good ideas
that people are working hard on
and, remarkably enough,
they're developing tests,
perhaps clues to, what
was the Universe doing
before it was expanding.
That's the next great
generation of experiments
in this subject.
There are ideas, as I said,
about what the Universe
was doing before it was expanding.
They go under the name of inflation.
Inflation is not a theory
because there are so
many options within it,
so many hypotheses to
be made and considered.
So, so far we don't have any firm,
oh we have very few firm
predictions out of inflation
and unfortunately most
of these predictions
were in effect post-dictions.
The theory constructed to fit
ideas that are now confirmed.
But they could change,
things will show up.
Search for gravitational waves
that would have been
generated by processes
thought to have happened during inflation.
Gravity wave detectors are being designed,
and not only will it
see interesting things
produced in the Universe as it is now,
maybe they'll see some
fossils from the Universe
when it was not describable
by an expanding world model.
- In your lecture yesterday,
you talked about certain
things that we know.
I don't, I want to be true
to use the right term,
but laws or principles of the uniformity,
no center, no edge.
I mean, these were the ideas
that have motivated the research,
and have been proved in a way.
You just mentioned that the Universe
is expanding but not evolving--
- [James] But evolving.
- [Both] And evolving!
- Yeah, yeah, and evolving, sorry.
- [James] Yeah, that's key.
You know there was a steady state model.
I like it as an example of an elegant idea
that has been ruled out.
We often, you know, in
in formulating ideas
about how the Universe around us,
the world around us, may be operating,
we do rely on our notions of elegance,
but of course our notions of elegance
are really strongly
informed by what works,
but the steady-state cosmology
is an example of an elegant
idea that was very influential,
drove a lot of research in part
because it's so infuriated some people.
Advanced the subject but then
was shown to be totally wrong.
So goodbye elegant idea,
let's look for another elegant idea.
I interrupted you a bit there you were--
- Well I know but I'm glad,
but going what I guess what
I wanted to talk a little
about some of the the
concepts that have emerged.
In your lecture, you were talking
about thermal radiation,
dark matter, dark energy,
and in your lecture, you
really conveyed the sense
of how our understanding
of these terms emerged
over time through generations
as scientists had an idea
which was either confirmed to disconfirmed
by satellite observations.
So, give us a feel for that,
so people can have a little
taste of that lecture.
- Okay, let us choose an example.
Well first let's notice that
you and I are made of atoms.
They go on under the
general name of baryonic,
bary being heavy,
well, historical term.
We are made of material
that is, to us, visible.
The striking evidence we have
from studying the property
of the Universe in the large
is that you, and I,
and baryons in general,
make up only five percent or so
of the mass of the Universe.
A little shocking.
- Yeah.
- But we'll have to live with it.
Pretty convincing evidence
that there is dark matter
that is not baryonic,
and whose properties
are really mysterious.
That there must be this stuff
was known already in the 1930s.
I mentioned Fritz
Zwicky, one of my heroes.
He was the first to point
out that we have a puzzle.
There's mass out there
that is not baryonic.
There are great searches going on,
including one beautiful
project headed up here
in Berkeley by Bernard Sadoulet,
looking for this dark matter
through laboratory searches,
brilliant stuff.
Then fascinating to me particularly
is the third major component
of our Universe, dark energy.
The name is really meaningless,
it was ad hoc, made up,
but it fits with dark energy, dark matter.
It had its origins already back in 1917
when Einstein had invented
his new theory of gravity,
general relativity, and found that
when he applied it to the Universe,
it gave an absurd answer.
The Universe can't be stable.
Of course the Universe is forever!
And so he adjusted his theory
by postulating a new term
that we now call dark energy.
He called it the cosmic constant.
It was a Belgian, George Lemaitre,
in the late 1920s early 1930s,
who recognized that
Einstein's cosmic constant
acts like a zero level of energy.
You know, in physics, energy is a quantity
whose differences we
care about, transactions,
but we don't ever set a zero of energy.
He became convinced that
the zero level of energy
is set by Einstein's cosmic constant.
I showed in my lecture
a fascinating exchange
of letters between Lemaitre and Einstein
just after the second world war,
in which Lemaitre tried
to convince Einstein
of the value of this concept.
Einstein would have nothing of it.
He grew to hate the cosmic constant
because he didn't think it was needed,
and if not needed then away with it.
To Einstein, simplicity is all.
I did remark that other
great scientists of that era,
Wolfgang Pauli, brilliant,
brilliant person,
would have nothing to do with lambda.
Evgeny Lifshitz from the Soviet Union,
a magnificent series of
textbooks in theoretical physics.
All of us learned so much from them.
They would have nothing to do with lambda.
- [Harry] And lambda is?
- Oh, sorry!
Lambda is dark energy,
it is the matrix dark energy,
it is Einstein's cosmic constant.
- [Harry] Mm-hmm
- To these people, it
was an ugly appendix.
And they had a reason in
part for thinking that
because we have the horrible
problem in quantum physics
that zero-point energy
is real and important,
and it's there and it exists
not only in material objects,
but in fields such as the
electromagnetic field,
but on an eve sum of the zero-point energy
belonging to the electromagnetic field
and other fields of nature
gives you an absurd energy density.
With all of the properties of dark energy,
Einstein's cosmic constant except one,
its numerical value is
ridiculous, forget about it.
There must be something wrong
with zero-point energy for fields.
I know of nothing wrong with,
the argument is I think clean,
except the answer is absurd.
It's an illustration of how
we have, on the one hand,
a secure, well-tested theory,
but on the other hand it's
only an approximation.
There are holes to be filled
by the next generation.
Well, what is now charming
is, on the one hand,
people recognize there
ought to be a zero of energy
that would behave like
Einsteins cosmic constant.
Lemaitre's dark energy, it ought to exist,
and through a series of
experiments that began again
in the 1930s by Edwin Hubble
who drove the development
of a big telescope to
make the measurements,
the 200-inch telescope on Mount Palomar,
by great scientists in the 60s
when that telescope was at last finished,
in particular Allan Sandage,
driving forth the
observations that might check
for this dark energy.
Then, just in our
generation, here at Berkeley,
Saul Perlmutter leading a group
to carry on those efforts,
and at last succeeding and
showing us of all things,
that dark energy exists.
The stuff that Einstein
introduced, then discarded,
that Lamaitre fought for,
that many serious scientists
discarded again, is there.
What a neat story.
- So, in a way, over time,
not in the sense of the scale of time
as one looks at the whole Universe,
but over time and over generations,
there's this movement forward to come up
with a concept that is confirmed.
Now in what sense in this process
does the dark energy matter?
I don't mean in terms of its utility
for practical things but relate that
to this ongoing conversation
of understanding the Universe.
- Yes, here it is,
the dark energy exists,
we should first pause to
say that ideas don't always
have the longevity of dark energy.
Many ideas are thrown
out and go away forever,
but some curiously survive,
often in a slightly different form,
but now for us at this very moment,
the key point is that we have the evidence
for the existence of new phenomenon
that does not fit within
our ideas of basic physics.
Something's wrong and we're
going to have to remedy it.
- [Harry] And that's dark energy?
- And that's dark energy,
its value is just wrong.
Now of course there's no crisis here.
There's opportunity of course,
but there are lots of ideas
about how to remedy this.
Down the road at Stanford,
Lenny Susskind knows, in his heart,
the solution to this problem.
(Harry chuckling)
Others of us wonder,
but that's part of the game of course.
- Now in the introduction in
the program for your lecture,
I'm going to read what it said,
and then I want you to
tell me what this means.
It says peoples laid the foundation
for the many modern
cosmological investigations
by predicting the existence of
cosmic background radiation,
popularizing the notion of
dark matter in the Universe.
What does that mean?
- Well it mean, with all due respect,
it isn't quite right.
- [Harry] Okay, let's correct
the program right now.
- This radiation, of
course, was first understood
before the second world war
by Richard Tolman at Caltech.
After the war, my teacher
Bob Dicke was the one
who said maybe there's this radiation,
we ought to look for it.
At that time, he persuaded two young guys
to build the instrument along the lines
he had invented during the war,
to look for this radiation.
We should just remind ourself
that it is radiation that fills space,
that pretty unambiguously was produced
when the Universe was young.
Has all the properties
of thermal radiation
that it could only have
acquired those properties
when the Universe was
young, and dense, and hot.
He said to me, "Go think
"about the theoretical considerations."
That set my career.
Some of the considerations I
invented were reinventions,
others were new.
So yeah, I guess I can
claim I did set the basis
for this subject in many ways,
but I certainly didn't start from scratch.
No one ever does, let's face it.
In particular, I was able
to do this as a postdoc
because the field of study,
of large-scale structure of
the Universe in the 1960s,
was so small.
There had been great interest
in the subject in the 30s,
but by the 50s and 60s,
interest had fallen away
to the point that I, as a raw postdoc,
had the field much to myself.
I could do all these interesting things.
I wrote the book that he
mentioned in the late 60s,
I think it was published '71.
Lots of stuff and it is wonderful!
I can do it all myself!
No one, no competition.
It's so different now.
Of course I don't regret the old days
because the subject is so much richer,
but it was an amazing opportunity for me
to do all of this interesting stuff
without looking over my shoulder.
- And, but then you,
as was said yesterday,
you laid a foundation that,
even if you didn't get everything right,
it became the benchmark
for the development
of exercises to prove that
there was physical evidence
for what you were saying.
- Yes, yes, it's true.
- And these were, in a
way, to make our audience,
I think you use the term fossils,
this cosmic background
radiation were like fossils.
- [James] Yes, that's right.
- [Harry] For the people in your field.
- Since the Universe is not forever,
it was different,
it must have left evidence of that,
and one fossil is this thermal radiation.
I talked about lots of others in the book,
and about lots of puzzles.
For example, it was clear even then
that there's something wrong
with our reckoning of mass.
I mentioned Zwicky and his mass anomalies.
I, in the book, collected many of these.
In part, I was simply
collecting bits and pieces
of evidence that some people knew,
but weren't realizing they
ought to tell other people.
- [Harry] Mm-hmm.
- Methods of analysis of
large-scale structure,
there were many things to be invented,
so well, what could I do, I invented them.
Analysis of the degree
to which the clustering
exists and is evolving.
The growth of mass clustering,
of course is key to our ideas
about large-scale structure,
because we are forced into this notion
that the galaxies are not forever.
When the Universe was
young, and dense, and hot,
there weren't any, and
there weren't any stars.
They grew through the
action mainly of gravity.
And the analysis of how that would happen
was certainly a large part of the book,
and of course there's
now almost an industry.
- Tell us a little about
either one of these discoveries
or this particular publication,
what your feelings were as
you came upon these ideas.
You've just suggested that a
lot of this had come before,
you were putting it together.
It was an uncrowded field,
so we were in the phase
of people didn't see
the importance of this
so you didn't have to worry about
what the competitors were doing
at this moment in time, and so on.
I want a sense of the factors that made it
possible for this to
happen on the one hand,
you mentioned some,
and then what your feelings
were as you were doing the work.
- You know, it occurs to me
that I was a little nervous,
and you might ask yourself
why is no one else
working on this subject.
There was a very good reason,
although we had bits
and piece of evidence,
they were rather scanty.
This was not a subject, at the time,
that was strongly supported
by observational evidence.
I do recall the feeling, now,
that many of my colleagues,
and my superiors, the tenured faculty,
although they never discouraged me
from working on this subject,
I got the feeling that they
were saying better you than me.
How do you know you'll make
progress in these great ideas?
How do you know you'll be
able to explore the Universe
at such immense distances,
and make sense of it, and
be able to piece it together
into a well-established theory?
I had no idea how far
this subject would go
when I was working on it in the 60s.
In fact, to begin with, I
think I remember correctly,
I thought well I'll stick with this,
write a couple of papers,
and then I'll do something
that makes some sense.
It really was very speculative.
How far could things go?
In fact, I know for sure that I shied away
from studies of the fossil
thermal radiation during the 70s
because as it was being measured,
the measurements were very difficult,
and the preliminary indications
from those measurements
was that this radiation didn't quite
have the properties expected of it.
So I went off and studied
the distribution of galaxies.
It wasn't obvious at all
to me that this subject
would have grown as rich as it now has.
Who could tell?
Technology advances.
- [Harry] So risk-taking,
that's something that comes up
with a lot of the scientists I interview,
that you go out on an intellectual limb,
I guess, one would have to say.
- How else are you going
to do something new?
- [Harry] Mm-hmm.
- And of course the limb can always break.
- Mm-hmm
(talking over each other)
- I must admit I don't think
I was at all being brave.
Maybe I was being oblivious,
(Harry laughing)
but also in those times,
remember this is not so long
after the second world war.
Education was ramping up
after the hiatus of the war.
Faculty were being hired,
although it's true I wasn't
offered any other job
than at Princeton,
somehow there was a
feeling I could get a job
if I needed it.
That's not so much the case anymore,
and it is a serious point of
concern for a young scientist.
Am I going to be able
to continue my career?
That's a real burden added
on to all the other things
you've placed on the limb.
I'm on the limb, I'm doing good work,
but the balloon breaks
because they can't find a job.
That is a real concern
that didn't occupy me,
and I think, although I don't
think I ever thought about it,
it was for good reason,
there were jobs.
Yes, but no, risk taking--
[Harry] And you mentioned
in your lecture a postdoc
whose name I don't remember,
who committed early in his career
to the development of the COBE satellite,
which became--
- Yes.
Talk a little about that,
because that was crucial
for providing the evidence
for some of these theories
that we've been talking about.
- Yes, I mentioned during the 70's,
the apparent evidence for anomalies
that didn't make too much sense.
That didn't make sense.
It was obvious what to be done,
build a satellite devoted
to the measurement
above the atmosphere where the observing
is much clearer.
There was a young postdoc,
a student of Paul
Richards here at Berkeley,
the graduate student
learned a lot from Paul,
then moved to the East Coast.
This is John Mather,
and as a postdoc decided he would love
to build the satellite
that could do the job
of studying this radiation
above the atmosphere.
As a postdoc, he recruited the help
of some of the major people in the field,
my dear colleague David
Wilkinson, a few others.
They got together, proposed
to NASA to build a satellite,
the proposal was accepted,
and Mather as a postdoc
stepped into the position
of lead scientist at NASA
to direct the building of this thing.
It's a very difficult job.
He has not only to understand
the technology and the science
but also to hold off all the bureaucrats
who want, for example,
to take away engineers
working on his project,
and put them on to some other satellite.
He has a marvelous book,
The Very First Light I think it's called,
in which he details the
agony as well as the ecstasy
of building such a thing.
Chapter after chapter of emergencies,
and who I turned to.
15 years of such work,
he is now approaching middle life,
and he has not a large record
of academic accomplishments.
It's all his eggs are in this one basket.
He has a deep respect
of a handful of people
who know what's going on,
but if that rocket had exploded on launch
and it happens.
- Mm-hmm.
- Where is his career?
Brave man.
- Where do you see the
the most exciting problems
down the road for this field,
and in what body of theories
will be most instrumental
in pointing the way which would
then have to be confirmed.
- Yes, yes, of course
it's always controversial.
Different people have
very different opinions.
Some will say cosmology is getting dull,
we've answered the main questions,
but I don't understand why they say that.
Well, perhaps I do.
We have answered some big questions.
Is dark energy really there, yes.
Is dark matter there, yes,
but what are these things?
And so we have right
in our face, up close,
big open questions.
Will we be able to answer them?
Time only will tell.
But of course there are
other directions to go,
and they are not necessarily
along the directions
we've been following.
For example, well, we
think we're so smart.
We understand galaxies, you know,
we don't understand our own galaxy.
Astronomers are starting to turn back,
there was a somewhat of
an imbalance in astronomy
in the past decade or so,
that the astronomy of the
nearby Universe was neglected
in favor of the glamour of looking out
to the edge of the Universe.
There is a definitely fads,
they operate in clothing styles
and they operate in science.
And the cosmology of the nearby Universe,
the science of the Universe
has studied by nearby objects,
was neglected.
In particular our galaxy
has been neglected.
Shameful, we live here, we
oughta look into it a little.
It has lots of fascinating properties
that will teach us about how it formed,
is teaching us about how its form,
and these lessons are just
being taught to us now.
So very clearly in the next ten years,
there's going to be a lot
more work on nearby galaxies,
studying in detail their properties
and teasing out hints to how they formed,
which of course is what
we attempt to understand
when we look at distant galaxies
seen in the past as they were forming.
Clearly that's going to be a big activity.
Finding nearby planetary
systems, fascinating.
Finding out if any of
those planetary systems
contain terrestrial planets, wow!
Is there oxygen on any of them?
How could you resist looking?
Styles change because, in part, technology
solves one set of problems,
opens up others that
maybe are so difficult
you will turn instead to
areas you've neglected.
And one thing about astronomy,
you know, we're in no danger
of running out of things to look at.
It's a big Universe.
- And what about bodies of theory
that might be brought to
bear on these problems?
Some, you know, in other
areas of the physical science?
- Well you know I am particularly
taken with the puzzle
of the body of theory of the dark sector,
so-called dark matter, dark energy.
We pause to consider that in our sector,
you and I and the things
we can see readily,
that interact with light.
We have a set of laws of physics
that are wonderfully simple.
They're not all that
simple but they're pretty,
you can write down the
basic laws of physics
on a couple of sheets of paper.
Its expression is
spectacularly complicated.
As far as we know you operate according
to the laws of physics,
at least to a good approximation
to the known laws of physics.
You are a spectacularly complex expression
of a simple set of laws.
In the dark sector, the laws of physics
as we now postulate them
are so amazingly simple,
but their expression is simple.
They're dull.
The dark matter piles up into
what we call massive halos,
the stuff the envelopes each galaxy.
The dark energy just sits there,
doesn't do much of anything at all.
Is that really the way it
is, or is it the simplest,
most ridiculously idealistic approximation
we could get away with at a
present level of knowledge?
I emotionally reject
that, strictly emotional.
I say I bet you there's
a whole body of physics
to be discovered that
will describe the behavior
of this dark sector.
Call again in 25 years and
see whether I was right.
- I'm interested in that emotionally,
so with that is a, let's clarify that,
it's a hunch based upon where you've been,
what you've seen, what you thought.
Help me understand that.
- Well you know let's face it,
I'm asking myself have I
worked myself out of a job?
Has the science of
cosmology come to an end?
It's in part,
by emotional I really
meant, oh my goodness, fear.
Perhaps over exaggeration.
Emotion, yeah, I want the
Universe to be more complicated
than it is, more interesting.
That's an emotion, isn't it?
It's a a hope, a longing.
- Yeah, yeah, it's an explanation
of what drives that emotion.
- Yes.
Yeah, yeah.
And it makes sense.
- I hope so.
- Well isn't that key
to, what, the enterprise?
- Yeah, I hope so.
- Yeah, yeah.
Okay, one final question and
that would be if students
are really grabbed by,
you know, the discussion
of your career and of
these set of problems,
how would you urge them to
prepare for their future
in this field, build the
groundwork, so to speak?
- I have no idea.
I have no idea.
Work hard, do your homework,
but keep interested in
the world around you.
- And it sounds like build things too,
in your particular field.
- Yes, yes, of course,
each side is different.
Some people build things a lot,
others don't, others have
never touched a hammer.
No, there are no universal
rules that I know of,
aside from do your homework,
but don't get locked up in your homework.
I guess that's the real trick isn't it,
because you know when we
teach students in university,
we set them exams in which the problems
are totally artificial,
because these are problems
that have solutions,
and known solutions.
Nothing you do in research
has a known solution.
If it had a known solution,
you wouldn't be doing it.
So we teach these
students the wrong thing.
It often puzzles me why
are we doing it that way.
Well the only answer I know
is we don't know a better one,
but the real trick for
developing scientists, I believe,
is not to get locked
into being totally adept
at answering already
known, solved problems.
Treat them as what they
are meant to be, practice.
Keep your mind ready
to address the unknown.
- On that note, Jim, I want to thank you
for taking the time to
have this conversation
and share your intellectual
odyssey with us.
Thank you.
- It's been a pleasure.
- And thank you very much for joining us
for this conversation with history.
(dramatic music)